if you want to grow your business land
bigger deals with bigger clients I'm
going to share with you three ways to do
it in this video hi I'm Evan Carmichael
I believe in entrepreneurs and I got a
question for one of my youtube viewers
love you guys m3 power who wrote in to
say hello I have a small electric
company in which I have two big
companies that I install lights for also
I have about four electrician's employed
working under me I would like some help
getting some information in ways I can
grow my business further and get more
contracts any help would be really
helpful thank you mallick amazing
question Malec thank you for the
question and congratulations on the
success you've had so far in building up
your business to have those two big
clients and building a team of four
people under you I'm going to share with
you the three things that I would do if
I were in your shoes right now
number one is network as much as I love
social media and YouTube and Twitter and
I spending a lot of my time there I
doubt a lot of your clients are on those
mediums a lot and so the way to get your
business happening is through old-school
old-fashioned networking you do it
through two ways one is by identifying
the companies that you want to work with
and then start asking everybody you know
if they know anybody who works at that
business because through a friend of a
friend of a friend you'll get an
introduction and your foot in the door
the other way is to again make that list
of companies that you want to work with
and go attend events where you know
they're going to be at where they've
bought a table where they're exhibiting
where their president is speaking be
there be a known quantity and introduce
yourself
it's a tried-and-true old-school
strategy but for you networking is the
way to go number two is Alliance
partners here what you want to do is
find people who you can ally yourself
with who are already serving the same
customers that you want to reach they're
not direct competitors to you but
they're selling complementary services
and products to your ideal customers you
want to make a list of those guys
introduce yourself to them and see if
there's a way you can work together
where they could potentially introduce
you to their clients and you could
introduce them to your clients if you
want your business to explode and grow
quickly Alliance partners is the fastest
way to do it and the number three is
starts small I've worked with a lot of
big companies some of the biggest
companies in the world like Microsoft
and Dell and American Express if you're
going in pitching a big company chances
are they already have somebody who's
doing what you're doing they're already
working with an existing vendor that you
are competing against and so the way to
land a deal is to make it simple stupid
easy to say yes to instead of pitching
them on some six-figure huge deal
start a lot smaller start with the
tiniest possible entry in and then over
deliver like crazy and wowed them with
your service so they are looking for
other ways to incorporate you into their
business when you start with a big
proposal on a big budget it involves a
lot of people it involves a lot of time
and involves potentially kicking out
current suppliers that greatly increases
the risk and increases the chance of you
getting a no if you start with something
really small with a tiny budget where
one person can make a decision and you
leave an impression on that one person
that's your chance that's your foot in
the door you go in you over deliver like
crazy
you're the best supplier that they ever
worked with and they will find ways to
incorporate you into the rest of their
business and of course continue to
believe thanks for the great question
for those of you watching my question
through you is how have you landed big
deals leave it in the comments below I'd
love to hear from you and if you liked
this video don't forget to subscribe to
the channel in the newsletter thank you
so much for watching I'll see you soon